we were just in the dining chance my my
friends came back from the rotation for
the ice fall down and then the ground
started to shake like we were on the
ship if the lighter got my iphone and
started to feeling you know I thought
it's going to be a blog or something and
then suddenly I noticed people start to
run and I turn around and I saw this
massive tsunami made of ice and then I
started to run myself and then what
happened when it all settled we heard
and we we may listen to some of it just
the effects on so many of you did did
you know what had happened at the moment
whenever lunch eat us or later on just
tell us about the confusion at the time
at the time I I just just like I was in
the movie I just didn't know what's
happening here what does it come from
what is it it felt so unreal and and
then what it really is ever yeah I
noticed it it's real answer I don't know
it just tells like it's hard to describe
I I think it felt a bit like is this how
it feels to die or something and I
couldn't catch any hair and my lungs
were just blown did you suffer any
injuries Yost luckily not luckily not
like like my whole team is good we are
very happy we just lots of tents and one
gear but we are all in good health
luckily